hi my name is Amit I'm an engineer on
the android framework team I'd like to
show you a couple of reasons why I just
love this phone let's say you have a lot
of contacts and you need to find one in
a hurry and you have only one hand free
instead of taking a long time to scroll
through all of these you can grab the
scroll tongue called the fast crawl
feature jump down to the letter of your
choice and then take it from there
the other feature that are really loud
when I'm traveling is to a new place
bring up the maps choose my location so
I know exactly where I am and if I want
to get a bird's-eye view of the vicinity
I bring up map mode choose satellite
view I know where I am I'm supposed to
meet someone at the volleyball court hey
that looks like a sandpit and I just
walked over to the sandpit and I find my
friend